[Music]  butcher  what happened my wife  she's alive what's holding the gap  of somebody and right now we're in a  little bit of trouble  are you [ __ ] with us  listen this is a [ __ ] mess we're the  most vulnerable ads in the country  we've got soup terrorists  and we got no superheroes hi  i'm stormfront who i'm the new girl  wonderful  oh god so what's your big plan  don't take that there we go can i get my  wife back  [Music]  these maniacs could be waiting for their  chance to kill us all  [Applause]  who the [ __ ] are you i'm just trying to  help  really how we are in a war  but we can fight back with an army  of supermen millions strong  no don't be a [ __ ] laser my [ __ ]  tits  [Applause]  that's exactly what we're gonna do  oh great cool totally one two three  we just need to keep our [ __ ] together  okay you guys go ahead you guys go ahead  i'm good  all right hands in the air like you just  don't care kill  [Music]  you